president biden has vladimir putin
committed war crimes
no comment from the american president
as he left the white house for the short
journey up pennsylvania avenue
they had gathered on capitol hill for
the key annual moment in america's
political diary but the state of the
union this year required a broader focus
speaker
the president of the united states
with the yellow and the blue dotted
through the chamber he pitted autocracy
against democracy good against evil
six days ago
russia's vladimir putin sought to shake
the very foundations of the free world
thinking he could make it bend
to his menacing ways
but he badly miscalculated
he thought he could roll into ukraine
and the world would roll over
instead
he met with a mall a wall of strength he
never anticipated or imagined he met the
ukrainian people
in the audience the guest of honor
ukrainian ambassador to the united
states is here tonight sitting with the
first lady
let each of us if you're able to stand
stand and send an unmistakable signal to
the world
ukraine
thank you
thank you thank you thank you
unity among nations was the key theme
in the battle between democracy and
autocracies
democracies are rising to the moment
and the world is clearly choosing the
side of peace and security it was this
message for those who surround putin
tonight
i say to the russian oligarchs and the
corrupt leaders who built billions of
dollars off this violent regime no more
the united states
i mean it and as he has so many times he
said again america would not fight in
ukraine would not fight russia but would
defend freedom however it can it matters
american diplomacy matters
american resolve matters
but at a time when american and western
resolve is facing its greatest challenge
in decades there were no standout sound
bites no george bush axis of evil
moments no this was measured calm
focused and yet it couldn't provide any
hints of how all this might develop how
it might end
as he left the president had a message
of support for his top generals
a man whose counsel he values and may
need in the weeks ahead mark stone sky
news in washington